it's hard to believe but it's been 15
years since the ring was released and in
that time this girl somehow turned into
this girl would you believe the actress
who starred as the waterlogged ghost gal
is actually a normal person in real life
here's what Devey chase has been doing
since she first scared the pants off of
us young breakout take away all the
makeup and CG corpse effects and chase
was big surprise a normal kid well a
normal kid with a growing Hollywood
career the year before the ring was
released chase voiced the lead in the
English dub of spirit - the way and
co-starred in Donnie Darko as Donnie's
younger sister Samantha in 2002 in
addition to starring in the ring she
also voiced lilo and lilo and stitch she
reprised her role for - lilo and Stitch
video games as well as the lilo and
Stitch cartoon series from 2003 to 2006
other roles Chase had a memorable arc is
the troublemaking team bride Rhonda
Volmer
on the HBO show Big Love from 2006 to
2011 she also appeared on TV shows like
CSI er charmed cold case and without a
trace and reprised her role from Donnie
Darko in the 2009 sequel ask Darko her
most recent projects have been
independent films including American
romance and Jack goes home LA life
though she grew up in Albany Oregon
Chase's Instagram feed could easily
double to tourism guide for Los Angeles
where she currently lives her views of
the skyline alone could be used for a
brochure the bulk of chases Instagram
account is dedicated to all the time she
spends with animals but she still has a
sense of humor about having once been a
young horror icon as evidenced by one
Instagram post asking should I be a
[ __ ] samara for Halloween Hospital
drop off On February 15 2017 Chase's
real life became a scene from a movie
TMZ reported that chase rushed a dying
man to a hospital in Los Angeles left
him outside and then left the scene the
site reported that Chase may have been
hanging out with him that day when
police ran chases name they discovered
an outstanding warrant for her arrest in
an unrelated case according to the New
York Daily News Chase is not a suspect
in the death and authorities have reason
to believe the man overdosed and the
actress was just trying to get him to
the hospital
arrest warrant leaving a dying man
outside
Hospital is an unusual move but it's
possible that chase didn't want to draw
any attention to herself seeing as she
had a warrant out for her arrest at the
time Fox News reported that chase was
arrested on February 22nd 2017 for a
traffic related violation
according to Fox News she was also
questioned about the unidentified man's
fatal overdose but at the time of this
video she does not face any charges in
connection with that death on the road
while chase said several filming
projects in 2016
her scheduled for 2017 looks totally
open from the looks of her Instagram
she's been spending time out on the road
in an RV and generally staying pretty
far away from the bright lights of
Hollywood whether the former child star
is finished with acting for good or just
taking a break for a while we can always
go back and spend some quality time with
Samara Morgan
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]